all right so we think that you all see
each other all the time because you're a
movie because we're dumb and like but
have you all seen each other in a minute
this is yeah I mean I've seen him like
all time
um but yeah I haven't seen you guys in
so long since England yeah wait you've
had your birthday since then right yeah
yeah I've heard the happy late birthday
yeah thank you I'm 16 now that's crazy
[Applause]
we were playing and I was like 16 years
old in this role of a lifetime I'm just
like you are living your best life ma'am
is incredible it's pretty crazy I'm just
so lucky to be here yeah well you're
very talented right when I said that it
was so funny Elizabeth is like she's
incredible in it and I'm like so I'm so
excited to see it but I have to say this
in a minute because in my lifetime I've
never actually met a human named
Benedict
on stage right now and I just think
I'm just saying that you both found each
other in the same film it's this I mean
I mean does anybody know Benedict nobody
knows Benedict right yeah it's just not
the pope yeah okay there was a pope
called Benedict not that long ago okay
okay but I'm like do you know the PO I'm
just saying do you know yeah yeah I
guess that's that's a common name it's
like Kelly or Elizabeth you know so I
was just like it's amazing that you
found each other and then what's even
more amazing is he's called Benedict
Wong and he's playing Wong yes I know
yeah we joked about having the Wong for
one campaign
we knew each other for a while we knew
each other way before this job oh really
yeah oh wow we've never had two Benedict
moments on set until no yeah yeah not
until March look what they did
um but you've said that Marvel is now
enter entering like a phase Wong so what
does this mean I like FaZe Wong by the
way I'm into it oh I mean you say one
drunk thing in a bar and then it just
chases you know doesn't it look how you
just handled that giant octopus thing
yeah that was uh that was a true story
then by the way
um yeah I I basically had an email of um
of Kevin feige that he was saying this
is fast becoming the wcu so I sort of
joke that it's a it's phase one at the
moment
um but yeah I love it I'm a huge fan I
was literally talking to my mom and
sister last night about interviewing
y'all and we all are such huge fans and
like we love Doctor Strange we're very
excited she was like I love it
um so um Sochi so you play a new
character so America Chavez so would you
describe her how would you describe her
I mean
you know she's amazing
um she's strong and powerful
um she can travel the Multiverse using
you know star-shaped portals that she
can punch and kick
um I love that I'm just so happy to be
playing her it's pretty crazy and this
is like a new character because I wasn't
into Comics like when I was young so
this is a new character right yeah
introducing it wasn't like from the I
love that yeah what's so great about her
is that she is 14 which is younger than
any of the versions in the comics so um
in this movie we kind of get to have
like a new introduction to her and
yeah that's exciting I know I'm very
excited um I'm 40 years old and owning
it I don't even care
um don't care yes don't care you know
what it's the little things in life that
make you happy
um so so what's been the coolest thing
about being in the like Marvel World
well I mean of course working with these
award-winning actors I mean that's I'm
pretty lucky
um but I I mean I used to have them as
action figures you know so it's pretty
crazy to be like friends with these
people
um now well now it's full circle and I
have my own action figure I mean there
is
I mean Benedict
Benedict Was there when I first when she
yeah when I was on set when she first
got it and I you know I get reams of
approvals for figurines and actually all
the rest of it so I'm like yeah yeah
okay all right yes all right more
plastic in the world great she gets it
goes
into tears I thought oh God the joy of
it you know it's such a moment it's kind
of cool to like re like you'd see it
through like a different eyes it hasn't
had that happen it's very much the
dynamic in the film at times I mean
she's she's a very powerful character
but there's a sort of cynicism yeah she
freshens that up a little bit so I love
that so you don't put up with this crap
is that your character I love you
I see okay I like it with the head shake
um so um so Benedict W sorry
um I heard that you liked to DJ on set
is this true and what's your favorite
music uh I do like to DJ if you need
some employment it's DJ Obi-Wan
that's amazing the story but people Sean
it says just DJ Obi-Wan
out of ten we should we share a makeup
trailer don't we so we're always kind of
putting the tunes out almost every
morning we would like play what kind of
hype music are you listening to it's not
Joni Mitchell what are we listening to
um also lots of lizzo oh I like it I
love your Rodrigo of course I love the
whole record well she's always trying to
pull me into one of her Tick Tock moves
but I think health and safety got
involved because I was really I put my
back out so we have an audience question
for the cast where is Cruz what's up
Cruz hi how's it going you can stand up
what's your question okay so I have a
question for you guys so I'm obviously a
big marble fan and
it has taught me a lot of really
valuable life lessons but I want to know
what has it taught you like being part
of the Marvel Universe oh Elizabeth
would you like to go first sure well I
think the character I play
um Wanda she's made lots of uh she's
she's very opinionated and through that
has has also found herself making
mistakes and I think it's important for
us to watch people make mistakes
um I mean I think we do that pretty well
with a lot of our characters and I think
it's important to show that kind of
process through working through
suffering of different kinds from that
and so so I guess it's real yeah so it's
been I think I've appreciated getting to
explore that um through through this
yeah what about you Benedict c yeah it's
again through the character I guess I
mean through making a Marvel film you
learn a lot a lot to do with patience
and pacing yourself patience
um but also I think the characters do
always that you know that's what's great
about those great laughs great action
there's great sort of enticement for a
spectacle as you know but there's also
something of the Zeitgeist or something
profound to take away for me for him
especially in this one it's learning
that you're you're stronger together
than you are on your own it's pretty
much the lesson I carry away from this
one without giving away boy drive that
one home for the world yeah listen yes
uh what about you Benedict W
um I I've just enjoyed overall what what
Marvel do with the these incredible
films you know it's about inclusion and
how we represent
um many um uh people of color and I
again as it talks about you know the
platform and opportunities that we have
with Shang Chi and now we have Miss
Marvel coming up and everybody gets to
see that like another hero that they can
follow so uh absolutely love yeah so
it's so important because I think
a lot of people are like you know you do
you know they want to see themselves but
also it
so to see other people in these roles
that's that's the bigger picture too is
like to make sure you're seeing everyone
for those kids as well yeah Marvel does
such a great job with that I feel like
yeah
[Music]